[Música]
mi país es peligroso para mí soy joven
tengo a
mi madre mi madre ucrania original tengo
muchos hermanos hermanas ucrania
ahora
sí
sé que mi
país ataca pero vuelvo a rusia
voy al ejército y
mato a mi hermano y hermana
[  Música]
está bien
[Música]
es injusto porque Estados Unidos siempre estuvo
abierto a los refugiados, era un país
de inmigrantes
y,
mira a tu alrededor, nos comportamos bien,
no corremos, no cruzamos la línea,
solo cumplimos con la ley
[Música]  ]
estos no son agresores rusos aquí
estos son disidentes rusos que también están
tratando de
protestar o tener opiniones en una posición frente
a la dictadura de putin se
enfrentan a persecución y tortura si
son llevados a rusia
[Música]
tú